[Music]
instead of congratulating Hillary
Clinton on her historic night and
withdrawing from the campaign Sanders
vowed to stay in the race despite the
fact that mathematically there's no way
for him to win now I know this has to be
hard on Sanders supporters everywhere
especially tough on his biggest
supporter here at our show our cameraman
Kyle I'm really sorry Kyle oh no don't
be sorry Conan this is far from a done
deal okay I know Bernie supporters say
that but it actually is a done deal it's
simple math Hillary has the delegates to
win so yeah if you use Wall Street math
where 99% of all numbers are not in the
top 1% of numbers
that doesn't make any sense yeah don't
worry under President Sanders all
numbers will be equal okay look it's
it's not happening Kyle okay also
Hillary has five hundred and seventy one
super-delegates so yeah but what about
the super duper delegate there are no
super duper delegates Kyle look it's
over the votes have been counted okay
not all the votes some of them could
have gotten lost in the mail or deleted
from Hillary's private Benghazi server
don't lose something it's not real you
can't delete votes okay what about all
the ballots stolen by birds who use them
to line their nests that's how Gore lost
no that's not how Gore lost
Conan we will not know who the real
nominee is until we check every bird's
nest in the country from the lowly crow
to the mighty eagle we must check the
nest who's with me
[Applause]
birdie-birdie I'm coming for you
you